[Music]
here at CGI you we bring together a
group of student activists and
changemakers every year to help them
think about how to maximize the work
that they're already doing or the work
that they feel called to do whether that
is tackling a challenge on their campus
or in their local community or around
the world we also hope that here at CGI
you and we help foster a community of
changemakers so that they can trade
ideas share ideas learn from each other
help each other get better and support
each other
when those inevitable challenges come as
the rubber meets the road and kind of
the hard work of making a positive
difference in the world maybe just a
little bit harder some days than others
one of the areas that we really focus on
here at CGI U is to try to be a platform
and a resource for our CGI u students
and alums and we think that's really
important because we want the CGI u
students not only to hopefully feel more
empowered and affirmed but themselves to
then help kind of democratize what
they've learned through the CGI u
process to other students other friends
the younger siblings or the kids that
they may themselves mentor now or in the
future and so kind of what does that
mean well helping CJ U students
understand kind of better and hopefully
feel more connected and empowered to do
what they themselves are doing but also
to really understand why at CJ u we
asked them to make a specific commitment
to action why we asked them to
articulate how they'll measure progress
against that commitment to action and
why we do think it's really important
that it be something new and not
redundant or repetitive to something
that someone else may already be trying
to do to tackle that problem kind of in
that space in that place at this moment
in time because we hope if students
understand better not only how to kind
of do the work that they feel called to
do but also why we focus on what we do
here at CGI u they'll be able to help
support more people to be more effective
changemakers today and in the future
[Music]
I think that Millennials and Gen Z often
get a bad rap as being kind of
disinterested disengaged disincentivize
kind of more curious about what's
popping up on Instagram then kind of the
headline of the day we've heard
critiques like that kind of for Time In
Memoriam and yet thankfully for time in
memoriam young people have said no you
know we're not going to be defined by
kind of your stigma of us we're gonna be
defined by kind of what we stand up for
what we fight for what we do kind of
what we push forward and I certainly
think all the students here at CGI you
not only provide a robust case for
optimism kind of every year and every
day and the work that they do but I
think really repudiate that and so I
think then the challenges for kind of
business leaders today or for kind of
NGO leaders today or for people in
government today is to recognize that
maybe young people are communicating in
a different way but they have profoundly
valuable thanks not only save but
they're doing provide a valuable work
today
and we'll all be better off if we have
the humility and the openness to listen
to learn alongside them and to support
so many of them that are making a really
very real important difference already
and we'll do so even more in the future
[Music]